you know we
spent a lot of time in the last couple
of live streams talking about the
confusion that the world seems to have
about what's going on in portland
and um the portland
rioters won a huge victory which is that
they
managed to invert cause and effect but
they got
an important photo op out of it which is
that the state
negotiated to have the federal
government withdraw
its officers now they're withdrawing
them
under the agreement that the state will
enforce the law which if the state had
done in the first place to federal
officers wouldn't have been necessary so
the idea
that you know we have driven out the
feds and you know
law order is now going to be managed by
one
we've agreed to do what we should have
been doing two months ago right and so
how is that a win for you
this doesn't fit with the idea that the
feds are fascists who
came here to beat people up because why
would they have agreed to leave and it
doesn't fit anything about the
uh the chronology but well i mean
i i i i can see
i i don't believe that but i can see
that uh they came and they were
interested in beating people up
being consistent with a they were sent
in order to solve a problem by someone
by by that was seen by someone else well
like i don't i don't believe this but i
don't think that's an inconsistent
interpretation no no what i think is
the local rioters managed to
um get the local authorities not to
enforce the law
leaving the only law and the only
relevant law given that they were
attacking federal buildings
as federal officers there needed to be
an influx i don't i'm not going to
defend
how they behaved you need more legal
expertise than we have to even evaluate
whether or not
that made sense or not but it certainly
made sense that you would have to
send federal officers to repel these
nightly
riots and the fact that those officers
are now leaving
is not evidence of anything other than
the state having agreed to do its job
however
it does open the possibility were this a
well-disciplined movement
that the movement would now become very
careful to halt the violence which
preceded the federal officers
arriving here because then that would
foster their story that they had been
reacting to an attack by the feds
but instead the narcissism of this
movement
is resulting in it suddenly having
no reason for being because the reason
for the world's attention is reduced if
there's not tear gas being fired at them
and there's no reason to fire
tear gas if they're not behaving
violently well maybe so just just to get
back to that last paper maybe it's not
the narcissism of the movement but the
combination of entitlement psychology
and psychopathy yes
um but one of the things they did which
i found
totally shocking um was hey zach can you
put up the video
yep so this is
a display out in front of i believe the
justice center
and this is the severed head this is
from when this is from
good lord yes this is uh
recently this is since since there's
thursday or later since the fed's pulled
out
um and you can see it appears to be the
severed head
of a pig i believe it is real they have
placed a
police cap a local police cap on it
or at least that's the way it's been
reported they placed it on an american
flag and they set it on fire
right so the obvious implication this is
an obvious threat of violence
against the local police right who are
the reason that the federal police are
now willing to withdraw
so these people are now being threatened
clearly with death if you
read and not very deeply into this and
um it also suggests something you know i
can't say for sure that they didn't
source the head of a pig from a butcher
and that this is all symbolic but
there's actually
reason to think that they may have
killed the animal because there are two
prior
incidents so zach can you show the
picture of the uh
the head next to the statue
no that one so this is a prior incident
in which
uh a severed pig's head was placed at
the base of
what was once the elk statue which was
then uh
burned and removed um and then
there's so much beauty in this movement
don't you find right and then here
in a prior incident a pig was found
wandering downtown
this is a live pig who's been blanketed
yeah somebody's put a blanket over it
and the police
rescued this pig and the interpretation
was apparently that
protesters had intended to kill it
ritually
um as part of their protest and i think
but we don't know that that's true i
mean it's also i think
the first time that a pig has been found
wandering downtown so it's clearly
somehow related
or that is the clearly the most
parsimonious explanation is that it is
related to the protests right that's all
i'm saying
is there's something wrong
with a person who is trafficking in the
heads
of animals in this casual way and in the
same way that i think
we are rightly frightened by
the child who cultivates their own
indifference to suffering by torturing
animals
i think there's something about the
choice of symbolism here
this is no longer graffiti of pigs heads
with their eyes crossed out which is
disturbing enough
in light of the fact that it subscribes
to this all cops or bastards and
can you put up the uh the graffiti on
the windows zack
okay uh there's a picture here so dead
feds i think the point is look
the message here and when is this from
uh
before they rolled out before they
pulled out i i don't know it was posted
this week but my point is the
the movement is trafficking in the idea
of
justified lethal violence against
all police you don't need to know which
police you are violent against they all
deserve it
and death is fine and we are going to
use
dead animals to symbolize our commitment
to this idea we are going to place it on
an american flag
the whole thing suggests a depth of
lunacy and disconnection from reality
that is
extreme and it could just be a few
people however
where exactly are the people in this
movement who say whoa
that does not speak for me
[Music]
you